did you have to be on the lookout for  sort of cultural cliches that you're  worried about falling into absolutely I  had to I was very self-conscious about  that I was constantly like facetiming my  friends or parents being like is this  proper are they saying this right am i  saying this right am i showing this  right also you have great when you hire  a great cast they will they work for you  for sure for for Michelle she was like  you can't have white lanterns at this  party that means funeral I was like oh  my god and my crew is like we can't  change all these lanterns like we have  to change all these lanterns you kidding  me so they change all the lanterns and  these things again was an experience I  was going through while making this  movie but it was down to that level it  was down to that level to detail